es ist mit hoher wahrscheinlichkeit eine
riesige sensation die fachleute jetzt
bei ihrer suche nach der mysteriösen
dunklen materie im italienischen
untergrund labors an grasser aufgespürt
haben
unerwartete signale die vom bisher nur
hypothetische teilchen also
vorhergesagten angenommenen teilchen
stammen könnten
sind die aktionen die dunkle materie
teilchen die urheber der signale oder
handelt es sich gar um die geister
teilchen namens neutrinos beides wären
hinweise auf eine völlig neue physik
klicks of science in future gibt es
dreimal pro woche spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal und aktiviert
die glocke nur dann verpasst ihr nichts
los geht's herzlich willkommen pixum
gibt es jetzt übrigens auch auf die
ohren und zwar als podcast die links
spotify und apple podcasts sind unten in
der video beschreibung das was
forschende jetzt in den messdaten des
sogenannten xenon einst experiments
aufgespürt haben könnte ein wink der
dunklen materie sein es handelt sich um
ein rätselhaftes signal das die
fachleute nicht eindeutig zuordnen
können zwischen februar 2017 und februar
2018 kam es wohl zu überraschend vielen
teilchen zusammenstößen mit elektronen
so heißt es in einer aktuellen
vorab-veröffentlichung die bislang noch
nicht begutachtet wurde konkret hat der
3,2 tonnen schwere detektor xenon ein
steak im untergrund labor unter dem gran
sasso d'italia einen signal überschuss
registriert also deutlich mehr zu
verzeichnisse als eigentlich erwartet
wurden und diese zusätzlichen
lichtsignale sorgen in diesen tagen für
extreme aufregung in der wissenschaft
community denn sie könnten von den so
genannten aktionen standen das sind
bislang nur hypothetische teilchen also
vermutete teilchen die aber als
aussichtsreiche kandidaten für die
mysteriöse dunkle materie gelten laut
der beteiligten forschende ist es sogar
sehr wahrscheinlich dass es sich um
diese extrem leichten partie gehandelt
und das wäre nicht weniger als eine
echte sensation erwartet werden in einem
jahr 232 lichtblitze sie werden durch
bekannte prozesse wie zum beispiel
radioaktive zerfallsprozesse verursacht
doch zwischen februar 2000 sie
10 und februar 2018 waren es 285 das
sind 20 mehr als es eigentlich sein
müssten 53 lichtsignale mehr als
erwartet dazu die italienische
physikerin elena april in einem
interview mit der new york times die
entdeckung eines neuen artikels wäre
phänomenal den theorien zufolge könnten
die aktionen milliarden mal leichter
sein als elektronen zudem sollten sie
nur schwach mit normaler materie
reagieren eine unzählige menge von ihnen
könnte beim urknall entstanden sein
und seitdem als dunkle materie durch das
als schwimm und so könnten sie bis heute
die gravitation von sternen beeinflussen
und nicht nur das in starken
magnetfeldern können sie sich
möglicherweise in elektromagnetische
strahlung umwandeln diese aktionen
wurden in der theorie vorhergesagt um
ungereimtheiten bezüglich der starken
kernkraft zu erklären warum wirkt die
starke kernkraft auf antimaterie und
materie gleich doch nicht nur das
aktionen könnten mit ihren speziellen
eigenschaften auch die urheber der
dunkle materie seien bisher konnten sie
wie gesagt aber noch nie nachgewiesen
werden klar ist ein direkter beleg dafür
dass die aktion existieren wäre
spektakulär denn das wäre endlich die
bestätigung für theorien in der physik
die schon seit jahrzehnten vorhergesagt
werden auch die annahmen zur
zusammensetzung der dinge in dieser welt
würden damit bestätigt der mysteriöse
signal überschuss im italienischen
untergrund experiment wäre zwar kein
direkter beleg für die dunkle materie
doch ein starker hinweis darauf dass
dieser teilchen typ häufiger im
universum vor kommt dazu der physiker nm
falkowski der nicht an der aktuellen
veröffentlichung beteiligt war
wenn sich herausstellt dass das signal
tatsächlich von einem neuen teilchen
kommt dann wäre das ein durchbruch auf
dem wir 40 jahre gewartet haben dann
kann man die bedeutung der entdeckung
nicht hoch genug ansähen
für die vorhersage und den nachweis
eines anderen teilchens des higgs bosons
bekamen forschende im jahr 2013 sogar
den physik-nobelpreis der könnte jetzt
auch winken bei den experimenten am
zenon 1 td lektor sind auch forschende
vom max-planck
den tod für kernphysik in heidelberg vom
karlsruher institut für technologie und
den universitäten in münster mainz und
freiburg am start sie alle suchen schon
jahrelang fieberhaft nach der
mysteriösen dunklen materie
bisher verliefen die experimente weniger
erfolgreich egal was sie macht und wie
stark sie sich bemühten
auch das pumpen des unterirdischen edel
gastanks führte bisher noch nicht zum
gewünschten erfolg doch jetzt eine
fährte führt sie uns vielleicht
tatsächlich endlich zur dunklen materie
von 2016 bis 2018 hatte xenon 1t den
auftrag die sogenannten wimps
aufzuspüren das steht für weekly
interacting massive particles übersetzt
also in etwa so viel wie schwach wechsel
wirkende massereiche teilchen man geht
davon aus dass die auch als schwächlinge
bezeichneten partikel eine große masse
haben elektrisch neutral sind und eben
nur in geringem umfang mit anderen
teilchen wechselwirken doch diese dunkle
materie teilchen sind bislang nur
hypothetisch und wurden einzig und
allein vorhergesagt um das dunkle
materie problem zu verstehen auch in
anderen experimenten weltweit suchte man
nach diesen ungeladenen massereichen
partikeln die mit normaler materie nur
sehr sehr schwach wechselwirken sollten
dabei galt der dunkle materie detektor
xenon 1t als äußerst erfolgversprechend
denn er ist auf den nachweis extrem
seltene ereignisse spezialisierter
bislang konnte keines der experimente
hinweise auf die existenz der bams
liefern den versuchsaufbau in den
italienischen alpen kann man sich
folgendermaßen vorstellen - 95 grad
celsius kalte szenen ein kaltes und
farbloses gas befindet sich bei diesem
versuchsaufbau in einem isoliert gefäß
hier würde sich die wechselwirkung eines
xenon atoms mit einem teilchen durch ein
lichtsignal zeigen heißt also sobald ein
teilchen von außen eintritt und auf
eines der xenon atomen trifft werden
elektronen aus dessen hülle geschlagen
und so kommt es zu einem schwachen
lichtblitz in der fachsprache ist vom
sogenannten cherenkov licht die rede
der us-forscher raphael lang sagt dazu
in einem interview mit dem tagesspiegel
geladene teilchen von außen können
weit in die xenon flüssigkeit eindringen
dank dieser selbst abschirmung bleibt
das innere volumen des xenos von
störstrahlung frei obwohl die xenon
atomkerne aus durchschnittlich 130
protonen und neutronen bestehen
zerfallen sie nur sehr selten und
verursachen daher auch kaum eigene
radioaktive störsignale dennoch gab es
herausforderung für das internationale
forschungsteam und zwar ströme von
längst bekannten und somit
uninteressanten partikeln und so kam es
immer wieder mal zu lichtsignalen obwohl
kein ungewöhnliches teilchen auf den
versuchsaufbau traf und so halfen sich
die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler anders und zwar mit
einer ard- hochrechnung hierbei
analysierten die fachleute wie viele
treffer ist in einem bestimmten energie
bereich geben sollte
das ergebnis 232 ereignisse doch die
messungen zeigen ein anderes ergebnis 53
treffer mehr als erwartet und somit
insgesamt 285 registrieren den teilchen
koalition mit einer geringen energie
dazu
der münsteraner physiker christian
weinheimer der an der aktuellen
veröffentlichung beteiligt ist nur
aufgrund unserer extremen reduktion der
untergrund rate konnten wir überhaupt in
den bereich niedrigste energien solch
einen geringen überschuss entdecken
eine mögliche erklärung für diesen
überschuss ist also das bislang nur
hypothetische teilchen aktion denn der
verlauf des gemessenen energie spektrums
entspricht nach angaben des
forschungsteams genau dem verlauf der
mann auch für die aktionen erwarten
würde
dazu heißt es in der veröffentlichung
die bisher noch nicht begutachtet wurde
die beobachtung solara aktion wäre ein
beweis für eine physik die über das
standardmodell hinausgeht allerdings
wäre dieser nachweis allein noch nicht
ausreichend um damit auch die aktionen
als ursprung der dunklen materie zu
belegen den aktuellen berechnungen
zufolge hat diese theorie eine
signifikanz von 3,5 sigma das entspricht
in etwa einer wahrscheinlichkeit von
rund 99,7 prozent dass das signal echt
ist zum verständnis in der
teilchenphysik gilt eine signifikanz von
fünf als entdeckung und das verlangt
eine wahrscheinlichkeit von 99 99 99
prozent also vier stellen
mit neun und nach ansicht der
forschenden müssten diese aktionen aus
der sonne stammen in ihrem umfeld
müssten sich demnach bekannte teilchen
in aktien umwandeln doch warum sind dann
manche stern typ mit nicht abgekühlt
wenn dort massenweise aktionen
entweichen dafür gibt es keine hinweise
und so ist diese theorien bislang noch
mit vorsicht zu genießen dennoch geht
das modell das die aktion für den signal
überschuss verantwortlich sind nach
ansicht des forschungsteams als
wahrscheinlich doch neben den aktionen
sind noch weitere erklärungen für den
signal überschuss denkbar auch neutrinos
die oft als geister teilchen bezeichnet
werden könnten dieses signal ausgelöst
haben
die signifikanz hierfür liegt nach
angaben der wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler bei 3,2 sigma auch das
entspricht in etwa einer
wahrscheinlichkeit von 99,7 prozent dass
das signal echtes und auch das wäre in
gewisser weise eine sensation denn wenn
es tatsächlich neutrinos waren die für
diesen signal überschuss gesorgt haben
wäre dies ein hinweis auf eine neue
physik denn das würde dafür sprechen
dass der magnetische moment der
neutrinos größer ist als es das
standardmodell der physik vorhersagt
jede menge physikalische theorien würden
damit also auf den kopf gestellt im
klartext heißt das also egal ob aktionen
oder neutrinos verantwortlich für den
signal überschuss sind beide fälle wären
ein anzeichen für eine neue physik und
danach suchen die forscherinnen und
forscher der teilchenphysik schon seit
ewigkeiten doch es gibt neben den
aktionen und neutrinos eine dritte
mögliche erklärung für das signal diese
ist anders als die vorherigen zwei total
unspektakulär und trivial denn
ausgeschlossen ist es bislang nicht dass
auch der überschuss durch eine seltene
radioaktive substanz in der detektor
flüssigkeit zustande gekommen ist
geringe mengen an tritium im flüssigen
zenon könnten also möglicherweise für
das signal verantwortlich seien hierbei
handelt es sich um ein radioaktives
wasserstoff isotope mit zwei
zusätzlichen extra neutronen wenn es
zerfällt sendet es ein elektron und ein
antineutrinos die wissenschafts
community ist sich im klaren darüber
dass bereits die zerfalls elektronen von
sehr wenigen tritium atom das signal
erklären könnten die fachleute haben
deswegen eine neue berechnung
aufgestellt und dabei berücksichtigt
dass ein teil der signale vom tritium
stand dann kommt das autorenteam auf das
folgende ergebnis dass solar aktion ist
noch immer das wahrscheinlichste
aber seine signifikant sinkt dann auf
2,1 sigma das große problem derzeit
besteht keine möglichkeit der zenon auf
spuren von tritium zu analysieren denn
schon seit zwei jahren ist xenon 110
nicht mehr in betrieb
er wird umgebaut und ende des laufenden
jahres 2020 soll sein nachfolger zenon
nt an den start gehen die xenon masse
soll hier dreimal höher und um eine
größenordnung empfindlicher sein
so könnten dann nicht nur die wilms ein
für allemal aufgespürt werden sondern
auch die aktion wenn sie denn überhaupt
existieren bis dahin müssen wir uns wohl
noch in geduld üben um dann
möglicherweise endlich herausfinden zu
können woher das überschuss signal
stammt bis dahin bleibt alles offen auch
ob es sich bei den registrierten
signalen nicht möglicherweise doch um
statistische schwankungen in den
messwerten handelt doch das
internationale forschungsteam ist
optimistisch und schreibt in der
aktuellen veröffentlichung vorläufige
studien basierend auf den resultaten
dieser arbeit sprechen dafür dass das
signal solar aktion mit zenon n t
schon nach wenigen monaten des daten
sammelt mit einer signifikant von fünf
sigma vom tritium hintergrund
unterschieden werden könnte
fest steht physikerinnen und physiker
weltweit sind wie elektrisiert doch es
sind dringend weitere versuche notwendig
dazu schreibt science mac die signale
reichen nicht aus um den nachweis eines
neuen teilchens zu verkünden aber für
hochgezogene augenbrauen
die hat übrigens auch lina man nennt sie
hochgezogen und das video xenon
kollaboration observe sein exzessives
xenon band dark matter experiment das
ganze also noch von einer super fachfrau
erklärt also anklicken anschauen und
abonnieren und ansonsten wie immer bis
dann bleibt dran